Welcome back to Gary's economics.
Today, we're going to explain why
rent, profits and interest are all the same thing.
So I wanted to bring it back to basics
and do a nice educational video
that is going to help you to understand
the way the economy works.
Now, I've always considered rent,
profits and interest
to be basically transformations of the same thing,
but I don't think many people think of them in that way.
So I want to explain why I think this
I think is going to help you explain
basically the structure of our economy.
Now, the first thing to say is
the title is not to be taken exactly, literally, of course.
There are important differences
between rent, profits and interests.
And we're going to explain them
in more detail in this video.
But in a very real important sense,
these three things are all the same thing.
And the way they can basically be described
is all three, rent, profits and interests
are payments
that are made by poorer people, the non owners of assets,
to richer people,
the owners of assets in order to use those assets.
And I think the best way to explain
how that works is to go through an example.
So let's say I've got half a million pounds
and you are a person who has nowhere to live
and you need somewhere to live.
So you come to me
and you say, alright
Gary, I've got nowhere to live,
you've got a half million pounds,
can you help me to get a house to live in?
We can do this
and we can structure this in three different ways.
So number one, the most obvious way, is
I use that half million pounds to buy a house,
I rent that house to you.
This is the classic landlord tenant relationship.
I buy the house.
I rent it to you. You pay me £25,000 a year rent.
Number one,
rents.
The second way we can do is I lend you the money.
I lend you the half million pounds.
You buy the house
and then you pay me
£25,000 interest every year, in order to live in the house.
So now you're paying £25,000, the same amount,
but in interest.
And the third way
that we construct this is, I set up a company,
I use the company to buy a house.
You live in the house.
You pay £25,000 a year rent to the company.
That company makes £25,000
a year profits, and it pays it to me in dividends.
So in all three of these cases,
I use my half million pounds to buy a house.
I'm allowing you to live in that house
and you are paying me £25,000 a year to live in the house.
But in situation one, I receive rent.
In situation number two, I receive interest.
And in situation number three,
I receive dividends from profits.
So you see from the perspective of me
as a wealthy person, as an investor,
once I have a certain amount of wealth,
I can buy, in this case,
the exact same asset, the exact same house
in three different ways.
And the financial structure
I choose around that purchase
basically determines
whether I receive rent, interest or dividends.
So for me as an investor, they're basically the same thing.
I have half a million pounds.
I want to receive some sort of passive income stream
and I can choose what to do. And for me
it's really easy to transfer between the two.
So let's say I chose the third option
and I bought the house in a company.
Eventually, I’m thinking, okay,
the structure of a company is not working for me.
I'm going to collapse the company.
I'm going to take direct ownership of the property.
Now I'm receiving rent directly,
so I don't want to receive rent anymore.
I want to start receiving interests.
Okay, well, I sell the house.
I'll buy government bonds.
Now I'm receiving interest from the government.
I can sell those government bonds
and I can buy mortgage bonds.
Now I'm receiving, again
your mortgage interest payments for the house.
That's not working for me. I sell it.
I buy the stock market.
Now I'm receiving company profits.
So from the perspective of the individual, it's
super easy to transfer between these things.
And I think,
I think ordinary people don't tend to realise that.
Basically, once you are a wealthy person,
you own a certain amount of assets.
Even by buying just the same asset,
you can choose to receive rent, interest, dividends,
which is profit. They're basically the same thing.
And in all three cases
that cash flow,
you know, many people describe these cash
flows on the internet as passive income.
In all three cases, it's not really passive income.
It's money that comes from you.
I own the house,
you live in the house and you're paying me your salary
to live in the house.
And this is basically what all of these things are.
These are payments made by you.
A poorer person who does not have assets
to me, a rich person who has assets
in order to use those assets.
And it goes a lot beyond housing.
Let's say you book a flight, you go to Portugal with EasyJet,
you go to the barber, let's take the flight situation.
You need a plane.
So as a very wealthy person,
I could own a plane and I could rent it to EasyJet.
And part of your ticket
will go towards that rental of the plane, which goes to me.
Or I could buy EasyJet stock. Part of your
ticket price goes towards EasyJet profits,
which comes to me.
Or I can lend money to EasyJet,
in which case part of your ticket
goes to interest payments again, to me.
So once again,
when you buy this ticket,
some of that money is going to me
as the owner of the assets.
If you go to the barber,
somebody owns that barber shop
and it could be that the barber is paying
rent to the owner of the property,
or it could be that the owner has taken a loan
to buy that property to pay interest to use the property.
Or it could be that
that barber is part
of a big barber corporation
and all of those properties are owned by the shareholders
and they receive the profits.
So in both cases, whether you’re taking a plane,
living in a house,
going to get your haircut,
you are paying some amount of money
to the owners of the physical assets that are being used.
The owners receive that in either profits, interest
or rent directly.
And you know,
this is even the case with the other
basic essentials that you need.
You know,
when you buy food, a big chunk of that goes
towards the owners of the farmland.
And again, that can take any one of these forms.
When you use energy to heat your home,
a big part of that money goes towards the owners
of the energy production infrastructure in our country.
Now, I want to talk a little bit about
a couple of big exceptions,
because I know there's going to be people
out there that say, listen,
if I buy a property
with a mortgage that's totally different from renting,
renting is money down the drain.
If I buy a house with a mortgage,
I can pay the mortgage off over time, I'm building up
equity in my house over time.
These two things are totally different,
and from one perspective, that is totally true.
If you as an individual rent a house,
you are not the legal owner of the house.
But if you take a mortgage and buy the house,
you are the legal owner of the house.
But let's go back to my example, right.
You know,
let's assume I've used half a million pounds to
buy a property, rent it to my sister.
She pays £25,000 a year rent.
If I lend £500,000 to my sister,
she buys the property, she pays £25,000 interest.
Now, assuming
she doesn't make any extra payments above the interest
in both cases, financially
her situation is exactly the same, basically.
She pays £25,000 a year rent
or she pays £25,000 a year interest.
So financially
there's no difference between these two things.
But there is one
very big important technical difference between buying with
a mortgage and renting,
which is who bears
the risk of changes in the price, changes in the value.
And I think this is the reason why people in this country
are so keen on buying with mortgages.
So if you rent and the price of the property goes up,
you are unaffected. You don't own the property,
but if you buy with the mortgage
and the price of the property goes up,
you take the, you take the profit, basically.
You take the upward movement in price.
And of course, in the last 30,
40 years, house prices in this country
and in most countries in the world have gone
very aggressively up
with only a few sort of downward hiccups,
which means that if you as an individual
have chosen to buy with a mortgage,
you would have done massively better
than if you have chosen to rent over the last 40 years.
But I think it's important
to realise the only real reason that
people have used mortgages
and paid interest
rather than people who have rented and paid rent have done
better is basically because prices have gone up
really aggressively.
If prices hadn't gone up
really aggressively., you'd be in
pretty much the exact same situation.
And I think it's worth
also recognising that if prices had gone down,
people who had bought with mortgages would have been
totally screwed.
If you buy a property with a big mortgage,
the price goes down.
You can become bankrupted extremely quickly.
This is what happened in Japan in the early nineties
when the housing market popped.
There was an enormous number of people
immediately bankrupted.
But I think it's
important to say I've said many times on this channel,
I think house prices will continue to go up.
So I'm not saying you shouldn't buy with mortgages,
but it's important to recognise that
both ways of doing it, buying with a mortgage or renting,
you will pay an enormous amount
of either rent or interest
to either
the guy who provided the loan or the owner of the house,
which is essentially the same thing.
There's no way of getting out of it,
If you do not own any wealth
and you want to live in a house,
you will pay these huge amounts of passive income,
either way. Using a mortgage or using rent.
The only difference is in one case you bear the price risk,
which is good if prices go up and they probably will,
but terrible if prices go down.
And the other way, you don't.
So I think the reason that this is important to understand
that rent, interest
and profits are the same thing
is because it helps us to recognise that underneath
these enormous amount of different cash flows,
which can take different names,
there exists a real country with real things.
There are
real houses, real commercial buildings,
there is real farmland, there are real natural resources.
And every time you use those things,
every time you live in a house,
every time you eat food, every time you use energy,
you are paying money to the owners
of those natural resources.
And whether it's called profits,
whether it's called interest, or whether it's called rent,
it's always the same thing, basically.
You as an individual
without wealth have to pay money to the individuals
who own the assets in order to basically live your life.
And this is essentially why
it's kind of inevitable that unless you
take some sort of preventative measures, wealth inequality
will and does tend to get higher over time.
And that's because, you know, you
as an individual,
you have an income of 30, 40 or 50 grand a year.
You spend the vast majority of that on
living in a house, eating food,
using energy, other essential costs.
And your salary goes in the form of profit, interest, rents
to the owners of the asset.
So after you've paid your essential costs,
you’re only maybe making,
you know, 10, 15 grand a year if you're lucky,
and the rest of your money has gone
to the owners of the assets.
So there's this massive constant drive of cash from the non
owners of assets, less rich people,
to the owners of assets, richer people.
And while that is happening,
these guys accumulate money
which they will inevitably use
to buy the rest of the assets.
So to conclude,
one of the big reasons I wanted to bring this up
is because I wanted people to realise that
because rent and interest are in many ways the same thing.
Owning property, but with
increasingly enormous amounts of debt
is very similar to not owning properties at all.
And the reason why it's important that you understand
this is generationally in this country,
whilst there is still a sort of big middle
class of property owners,
those property owners are increasingly needing
larger and larger amounts of debt
in order to own the properties.
So if we consider my granddad's generation, by 40
in many cases
they would have paid off the majority of their mortgage
and be close to owning their property.
Whereas my dad's generation
would probably be about halfway there by 40.
And my generation will, in many cases,
still having 90 or 80% mortgages
by the time they're 40 because they will
in many cases have only just bought.
And I think this ties in nicely to the video from last week
where we spoke about the illusion of improvement.
And the way that individuals
when they focus narrowly on their own
financial situation, may feel that they are improving,
whereas generationally
their family is getting poorer over time.
So individuals who own their own property with a mortgage,
they will be slowly paying their debt down
and they will often feel like I'm doing
when I'm getting richer without realising
that their children and grandchildren
are in a much worse situation,
largely because of the much higher property prices.
And will need to have much higher levels of debt.
So even though you
as individual are becoming less indebted over time,
you as a family are becoming more indebted over time.
This is really important to understand.
It's happening to our governments as well,
and governments are increasingly going in debt
to the rich, paying large amounts of interest to the rich.
Families are doing the same thing.
This is a big way that we lose our middle class
and our country falls into poverty.
So you need to be aware.
You need to understand interest,
rent, profits all the same thing.
Payments made
from poor people to rich people
that make wealth inequality get higher.
We're going to keep talking about it
until we understand it. Thank you very much.